how are you doing
i'm doing good i'm doing good it's been
a long day of press but a good one good
conversations
uh hopefully i won't uh screw it up
let's keep it going
um so because i have 15 minutes i have a
wide variety of questions
and i'm going to start with um i
jokingly am going to ask you do you
think you post on instagram too much
no i'm really bad at instagramming and i
i
yeah which i mean do i wish i don't know
i don't know i feel like
um i've always been quite private in my
real life in general you know and i
think that um
yeah i should probably get better at
instagram i don't know whatever i'm
rubbish at it i prefer it's human
interaction you know
completely um what's cooler uh
being on ted lasso or having martin
scorsese following you
on instagram
um that's a good question
i mean marty is one of my all-time
heroes and uh
but ted lasso is just filling me with
more light than i knew i could be filled
with so
i don't know i don't know i think that's
actually that's that's an impossible
question to answer
i'll let you i'll let you slide um what
tv series would you love to guest star
on
oh man i mean i'm a huge stranger things
fan but sadly i think i'm probably
i i sit right in the middle of being the
children and the adults i don't know
but i would i absolutely love that
show a lot i'll pass on to someone i i'm
friendly with sean levy
i'll say that you love the show i'm sure
he gets it all and today i would come in
and literally just be like a pizza
delivery girl or something i would
i would do that a hobby i absolutely
love stranger things i love those all
those kids i just find them so dynamic
and i
yeah that kind of throwback to the kind
of
80s um kids finding these
alien creatures yeah i love it it's
brilliant
i am curious your dad is a successful
director and you grew up
with like i guess inside the industry
seeing you know him work
did you know at a young age that you
wanted to act
yes definitely i remember it vividly the
first time i kind of felt a
shot in the heart of it was i was um
about four
and i had really bad chicken pox and um
i literally wanted to exit my skin like
a missile
and um my dad had a an amazing laserdisc
collection and a projector screen and he
put on labellabet
on laserdisc for me at four years old
and i forgot that i had chickenpox
yeah and i remember just thinking like
i thought my magic's real
and um that yeah got bitten by the bug
then i mean obviously i don't think i
understood entirely what that meant at
that point
but i remember i remember that so
vividly i remember the dress i was
wearing and everything i remember really
vividly but it wasn't until i was about
14 i actually told my parents i really
wanted to do it
i watched vinyl um and i was surprised
that it didn't i know it got picked up
for a second season and then it got
pulled back they said we're not gonna
make it
um what was it like uh did when you
signed on for that
were you like this is going forever
martin scorsese is producing this thing
this thing is going to be
you know you know i
had experienced a few things in the
industry in my career thus far up until
that point where
people had made projections and then
they turned out to be false so i'd like
quite quickly to not try and predict the
future with that kind of stuff but
what was really hard about vinyl it was
actually the first tv show i ever
auditioned for because i was so nervous
at the idea of making a commitment like
that where you sign a deal for
you know years of your life i was like i
can't even decide what shoes i want to
wear for an hour
a day you know it's like god that's a
commitment and um
uh then i was really
committed when we did i got part and it
was an extraordinary process and then we
shot it and my god i love that time
period i love the music from that moment
and i love
that that we were in new york and that
we were i just yeah i loved everything
about it and that we got picked up for a
second season
and then it was ripped away like that my
heart was broken
i was like oh my god it really felt like
a loss
and um a mini you know one of
my own personal mini tragedies in my
life and so then for a long time
afterwards i was kind of nervous at the
idea of doing tv again because i was i
guess you
experienced a little trauma from that
and um ted lasse was the first time that
i
was open to the idea of committing to
another long
term potential journey and uh
um thus far we haven't been cancelled
um and we have started shooting season
two so hopefully
but um you know i think i i've never i
never sit too comfortably
in an experience anymore because i i am
aware that it could all get taken away
and i
really treasure it so i make each moment
count as much as possible
oh i i definitely have some ted lasso
questions but let me jump into why i
actually get to talk to you today
uh with palmer um what was it about this
film
and this character that said i have to
do this
and that is a big cup of coffee isn't it
just i know
it well it was really full oh yeah too
actually only minutes before i hopped on
with you but um
uh what about this character i mean
everything
all of it i i this little
you know insight into this woman's life
this little
arc that happened in this script um
to me was a powerful one in an already
extraordinarily moving and powerful
uh story that um was
brought to my life because justin
actually recommended me to the director
and um again still to this day i'm kind
of
blown away that he thought i could bring
life to shelley because i think she's a
really complex and really
really nuanced an interesting character
but it's interesting doing press how
people react to her you know because i
i know how i feel but i'm not gonna
predict how anybody else feels about her
and um
i had such empathy for her and um
and you know i think
yes there's a lot going on with her
she's a drug addict she's
living in a trailer that she can't
really afford to keep food in and she's
got a
boyfriend that's not kind and not the
right guy to be with and she's all of
those but at the same time
she's a child herself and she has a
child and she hasn't got the tools to
mother this child
but my god she loves them i think she
loves him so much
that it can suffocate him sometimes
actually
and she she's they're best friends they
they she's his equal and i found that
um a very precious and
and awesome thing to to play actually
definitely due to the fact that ryder
who plays sam was such an extraordinary
little human
and i mean an amazing actor
but him and sam are quite similar you
know they have this incredible
um way of looking at the world and
taking things in
and this wonderment and this profound
kind of
enjoyment of of learning about things
and seeing things and knowing things and
then sharing that information with
people around them
and without any judgment at all
and that's another thing that i thought
was really lovely about shelley is that
she doesn't judge sam never
never and i don't think she judges other
people i think the person she judges the
most
herself and that's why she is in this
kind of whirlwind of addiction which
um ultimately she's losing the battle
with at this moment in her life
and um i imagine sadly doesn't bode well
for her but
you know i think she makes um an
uh a brave decision and
[ __ ] hard decision at the end of the
film to
set her son free because she realizes
otherwise she's going to keep him
captive and he's not going to be able to
go and
prosper and live the life that he should
i mean who wouldn't want to play that
role
the thing that i find interesting about
the writing is that shelley
is i mean she's kind of a mess but her
love for her son
it's like a lot i think a lot of times
in a script like this she would be
just bad across the board you know that
there would be no redeeming quality
but the interesting thing about the
script is that she really does love her
unique son and it's like that you know
that real love
um and i i think that's what makes the
script you know different
and uh better yeah and i think it's also
you know it's from the get-go she she
like i think the adoration
yeah is so um
present from or it was from the
beginning of the script and and i think
that
uh when she comes back after having
disappeared on this
you know wild bender and comes back and
she's almost kind of unrecognizable and
she's
frightening to her little boy she
expects him to love
her as he did when she left
and that's also an incredibly kind of
childlike way to approach
returning to a situation you know
because that's a tall order
and she's been gone for a long time and
she comes back and she doesn't look like
his mommy really
you know and then you see this very
child like
character of the mom smothering this
little boy being like i need you love me
and you see this boy kind of like oh my
gosh and
but underneath it all you see this kind
of fear in her eyes of
him not loving her and she doesn't know
what to do if that's the moment
that it's gonna happen she's not ready
for that you know so i think it's uh i
think it was a really interesting
written
part because there is a sort of
desperation in the love for her child
too which ultimately is what she
realizes at the end when
um sam is chasing after that cop car
that palmer is in
and she observes that and she really
realizes if
i was in that car he wouldn't chase it
and i think um
i mean i'm not a mum yet i hope i am one
day but the idea of that
realization happening i think would feel
like being sliced into with a machete as
a mother
so what do you do you either hold your
child captive
um or you let them go
uh i could ask a million other questions
but i am such a huge fan of ted lasso i
have to talk to you about it
so i'm gonna i'm gonna jump in on that
because um
as you said when you sign on to a series
you really never know what it's gonna be
until
you make it and until the people see it
and their reaction
it has to be amazing to be a part of a
series like this that is universally
loved it's extraordinary also
you know if you've um been privy to
a lot of my career i've spent a lot of
time i think making very interesting
choices but choices that not a lot of
people have seen
so i think that um it's this is kind of
a new experience for me and also
again to be a part of something that is
truly through and through
filled with a positivity i feel like
i've also taken a lot of roles that
are very dark and not that i think
ted lasso doesn't have darkness to it i
think it's got real humanity to it which
is why
it feels like you can relate to it you
know even
being in it there's so much of it that
i'm not in when i watch the season i was
like
oh my god i felt that each character so
deeply their journey was like
every one of them was so human you know
and and
yet laughing through it which i think
that's kind of how we survive
isn't it we laugh through the stuff that
we find tough and then
hopefully and i think ted lasso is again
a kind of positive
example of reminding humans to do this
but enjoying the moments that are good
yeah completely um you've started
filming season two
thank god uh because i need that show
back um what can you tease
about uh season two without getting in
trouble
nothing at all other than we started so
that's amazing
and i i i've just i'm really grateful
for a character like keeley in my life
right now she's bringing me a lot of
light
which is really cool to be playing again
well i'll ask you this when you signed
on did they tell you
we have a three-year plan we have a
five-year plan we we have an arc for
your character
we have an arc for the show or how much
was it you know like
this is what we're thinking you want to
be a part of it so i i got
uh i got a text from jason initially
actually because i
um i had met him quite a
few years before and um
genuinely when he reached out i thought
he'd accidentally text the wrong actress
because he was reaching out about a
comedy
um about a you know
football team in the and i was like
first and foremost comedy i think he's
thinking of the wrong
actress like i'm known for literally
like really dark roles what's going on
and then figured out that he hadn't
reached out to the wrong actress and he
wanted to chat with me about
it and um i went and had a drink with
him in la and he explained
the universe to me and kind of what his
uh
his idea for the the story was and
how he kind of wanted it to play out and
what kind of
comedy and what kind of humanity
there was going to be involved in it and
yeah he gave me you know insight into
what keeley's journey would be
and i was completely amazed by
what came out of his mouth and i was
like yeah
i am so game bring it on are you sure
you want me you know and um yeah it's
still
it's still i'm still reeling from it you
know i think
making the show was so much fun and all
the cast and the crew that were a part
of it on season one and
now again season two are so
brilliant and so um
all so funny but also human and it feels
like
we're getting to um explore
life with this show but in a positive
way
if i'm not mistaken jason is a huge
pinball fan
um i'm not sure if he's if he has uh
ever told you that
i didn't know that i know he does i know
he's big at magic
big magic fan and does really good magic
tricks and stuff
oh i was going to say next time you see
next time you see him on set uh talk to
him about pinball
okay i mean i'm going to see him on zoom
in a few hours actually but i think i'm
yeah i'll ask him about them
yeah just just tonight just an idea um
when do you actually
how has covid impacted the shoot in
terms of
would you normally have wrapped in like
four months and now um
uh you know now it's gonna be six months
well we've joyously been picked up for a
few
a few extra episodes this season so it's
a longer shoot
due to it actually shooting more too but
um
thus far how has it affected that time
and stuff it i i haven't
felt that entirely it's just interesting
because when you're not actually
in front of the camera and the camera's
rolling you know you have to put on a
like a z shield sort of visor thing or
wear one of your face masks so that does
feel like
a moment of oh i want to be able to just
to take it off and hang out with my
friends and like
you know i think we've had such a cool
week with that
you know really lovely um news about
awards and uh just an extra
encouragement to continue
making the show also a like hit of like
panic oh my god wow okay we've got to
really bring it don't stop keep going
and
uh but like finding out you know jason
getting nominated for golden glow in a
sag award and then the show getting
nominated for gold and blue
but and then you know a psycho
nomination for
ensemble cards and you can't hug your
classmates you can't like
throw your arms around them and say i
love you so much yes
how cool so proud of us now let's get
back to the scene and [ __ ]
kill it you know it's like that's hard
and i find like
i've moved my body because you start
finding weird ways to be like
like you wiggle out love and joy for
people so that's
new i feel like there's a new kind of
physicality of explaining
your joy to be around people because you
can't
actually embrace which is hard i
understand i listen i could keep on
going but i gotta rap
i'm just gonna say i'm really happy for
you congrats on everything that's
happening
and have a fantastic day yes you too
take care be safe